[Music]
all right so mark zuckerberg's sister oh
yeah right okay so yeah
[Music]
so uh yeah okay so anyways so apparently
she
is very into crypto now
right and i i guess there's this some
history it's actually in this twitter
thread um
whoever this is she
says
that uh basically like mark zuckerberg
banned all crypto ads and all crypto
related posts on not posts but ads on
facebook oh for a long time because they
were trying to do their own coin and
they didn't want any competition i don't
really know any of this history i don't
know if that's true or not but um
now randy is really into crypto and
she's really into like empowering women
in crypto because crypto is
traditionally a pretty
male dominated field right right so one
of the ways that she chose to you know
lift the women up and kind of like
um you know raise awareness for women
and crypto is by making this song okay
we're all gonna make it
yeah
this is a reboot
yeah speaking of bad reboots
we're
is this her voice yeah just this thing
well she was a broadway she's like
saying this on broadway i guess
right or saying something yeah but don't
on broadway don't try to find an excuse
you just want to sing yeah
you know she's this whole like oh we
should empower women through a song yeah
all these people are like now what if we
just did like you know like some
seminars and like some education type
stuff yeah yeah but a song would really
oh it hit help him
you know women love music yeah yeah but
we shouldn't you know categorize you
know women like a lot of things
i think we should offer a lot of
different avenues for women to engage
nfts yeah but like
we should do a song right guys yeah
right right right oh i actually i
[ __ ] did this song on broadway
a long time ago i just do that again
yeah i mean that that could be cool yeah
i sang it on broadway so i'll just sing
it again here for yeah well let's do
that we'll do that have you guys heard
of bobby schmerda when she plays the
song and starts performing this [ __ ] in
the office
crypto
i'm thinking about remix of bobby [ __ ]
yeah
that's randy [ __ ] i'm ready [ __ ] no
i'll give you a handy [ __ ]
nice
[Music]
first of all
this is just so funny because it's like
she's just projecting her old into this
yeah like women like just women standing
on the sidewalk watching a video
landscape yeah a modern woman watches a
video landscape in the middle of new
york it's like they're [ __ ] holding
it vertical like they're normal but also
like the shoe horning of all the
acronyms in here like it just we're only
what 30 seconds in yeah and she's used
wag me and now she's about to use like
50. oh wait can we even watch this [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
we can it's not covered no it's it
didn't do it on my channel so we're fine
oh so it's it's been so long that this
song is now out of copyright it's just
like a public domain yeah i guess i
guess
that's how old this [ __ ] is
yeah 80 [ __ ] is public domain go crazy
[Music]
can we back up like
20 seconds so i can hear the [ __ ]
again
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we love joy
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
women singing in public
that's what that guy was thinking a guy
he's from the 20s the hell is this yeah
he's from 1920 looking through this
little screen being like women are not
supposed to be outside yeah what the
hell yeah
nice
[Music]
i've watched this plenty of times
that's the guy that cut me from the
[ __ ] pilot yeah yeah yeah that's him
dude yeah
that's the suit
he just like the whole video interrupts
and he looks through the screen he's
like cody i know you're round ass isn't
talking about my phone get a jawline
[ __ ] don't you ever [ __ ] audition
for my [ __ ] maybe what a cassie if you
don't if you didn't eat so many bagels
all the time egg face looking
[ __ ] why don't you lay off the
jalapeno cheese dude those are good
though those are fired
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay i think we're good right
i think yeah that that what a face to
land on with the tongue and everything
just
what i mean like
you know for someone like this who
clearly like wants to sing and and
display her voice what other song
do you think would be ideal for a person
like that to sing online
oh brother
oh let me let me think about that
it's on the screen right now so don't
look i didn't i looked but i didn't read
it like
i'm just trying to think who has like
like type
no no like
think slower i mean adele
this [ __ ]
landscape
[Music]
hello
it's me
would you like to learn about exchanging
cryptocurrency
we'll go over
just sing
like that's what you want to do
there's nothing to the crypto man
i mean you might like crypto but you
your ass wants to sing
just go do that
she's like look i want to cover this
[ __ ] song and i think i got a dope
ass voice so i'ma just do it
yeah just do that
and then at the end of the video you can
be like this is sponsored by my crypto
foundation yeah yeah which fuels my
singing career
everything
[Music]
cause you got coins from different
blockchains and want to do some trading
hello
it's just so oh same guy oh [ __ ] suit
recurring yeah he's not he's not good
for this he's not good
yeah the chin it's just not
it's two egg too much egg
as the kids would say it's giving eggs
you know yeah
and you hear me
a
decentralized exchange lets you convert
from a to b
once you pay the
gas fee
what's he got to say
and no single point i didn't think women
could say
women what does it say is this these
laws yeah yeah where does it say here
women are allowed to sing
i didn't know women were allowed to be
outside that's crazy that's that's his
line in every video yeah
so you're telling me that women go
outside of the home
that is surprising
it's like they just like they took a
song
and then they like they just took a
bunch of crypto terms and they're just
like
rammed it in just jamming it and just
just working with [ __ ] foot you know
yeah
they don't fit
yeah you know
it's like when you like you're packing
up a car with suitcases there's just not
enough room yeah
trying to tetris them in there yeah
it's not working we're just not bringing
the bowling balls dude yeah just leave
them
yeah this is this is like a
do you think mark gave her any money i
don't think so not
well not with these music video budgets
i mean like i was saying the the first
one wasn't that poorly produced
it shot that on like a nice camera
well you know what it is also that like
takes away from it is
3d graphics like that
feels so corporate only corporations use
[ __ ] like that yeah no creative person
uses that type of [ __ ] yeah no it felt
like an all hands video yeah
oh
i felt like my l5 just
shattered when you said that you
remember when we did that sketch for
full screens
oh damn it yeah
we had to like be like space guys yeah
we like space guns we've been we've been
with this space team for a long time
yeah yeah we'd like
we like parodied men in black or
something yep they like kill some zombie
yeah
yeah then my head exploded yeah or your
head exploded
one of ours did both of ours did
actually oh was that what it was and
then we just had to fall out of frame
yeah
damn what if they'd give that to us
i don't know i'd put it on my reel
probably yeah
you know the full screen all hands video
i did the full screen all hands video
yeah the only part i liked is when his
[ __ ] head exploded
[ __ ] yeah when his egg head just like
loved that for him